once I believe nations greetings from
Copenhagen Denmark my name is Evan my
one word is believin I believe in people
more than they believe in themselves and
my hope is that a little bit of that
rubs off onto you so you can create
something amazing in this world so to
help you on your journey today we're
gonna look at five lessons in life the
people often learn too late and
hopefully you can pick it up a lot
sooner lesson number one is don't
sleepwalk through life
I advise students as much as possible
look for the job that you would take if
you didn't need a job I mean you know
don't sleepwalk through life and don't
don't say it's all gonna be great you
know I'll do this and I'll do that and
you know I'm just marking time does it
to be older that I've told people that's
like saving up sex for your old age I
mean it just is not as in it it's not a
good idea yeah
what what are you urging them to do
guess what I'm talking about it just
yeah you really want to be doing what
you love doing and you can't necessarily
find it on your first job right but
don't give up before you find it
lesson number two live life without fear
if there was one concept that I would
suggest to people to take a daily
confrontation with his fear the the the
problem with fear is that it lies right
so fear tells you hey you know if if you
say that to that girl she's gonna know
she has you you know and she'll never
really be attracted to you if she knows
how much you attracted to her don't say
that know how we get her is when she
walks by ignore her fear tells you dumb
like that you know you know for me the
the daily confrontation with fear has
become a real practice for me since
about three three years ago I went I
went skydiving in Dubai right and
skydiving skydiving is a really
interesting confront with fear right so
so I got I got a stand-up so so all your
friends what happens you go out how you
oh sorry I'm I think so what happens is
you go out the night before and you you
know you take a drink with your friends
and somebody says yeah we should go
skydiving tomorrow and you go yeah we'll
go skydiving more yeah yeah yeah
Yeah right and you go home but you by
yourself you like mmm right you're like
well I mean they was drunk too right so
so maybe maybe they not maybe maybe I
mean we don't have to go we don't have
to do it so then that night you're
laying in your bed and you just keep and
you're terrified you keep imagining over
and over again jumping out of an
airplane and you can't figure out why
you would do that right and you're
laying there and you have the worst
night's sleep of your life but you still
have the hope that your friends were
drunk right so you wake up the next day
and you go you know down and you say
where you were going to meet and
everybody's there you're like all right
all right cool cool cool cool cool cool
right so you get in the van and you
don't know that your friends have the
same night that you had cuz there
pretended like they didn't it like yeah
man my uncle is a Navy SEAL and you know
this is gonna be great I've been looking
forward to this you like oh my god oh my
god and your stomach is terrible you
can't eat and everything but you don't
want to be the only punk who doesn't
jump out of this airplane so you get
there and then you have this safety
brief and you're standing there and the
guys that tell you what the chute
doesn't open what's going to happen is
you're doing you a lot of help with what
could happen that the chute the chute
wouldn't open right so you do a thing
and what you do is your first jump
you're attached to a guy who is going
you know he's going to walk you out so
you go and you get there and there's an
airplane and nobody stopping everybody's
still going so you get onto their
airplane and you're sitting there and
and you know it's extra because you're
sitting on some dudes lap some stranger
you sit on his lap and it's not you know
you got trying to make small talk yeah
man
so you deal usually you'll be jumping
with people all the time right you know
so and then you just want to make sure
you got you got kids right you got
people you need to see right just want
to make sure he's serious right so you
get in there
so everything's normal so you fly and
you go up you go up you go up you go up
to 14,000 feet and you notice there's a
light it's red and it's yellow and green
right so right now the lights red so
then you start thinking at some point
the lights going to go green it but you
don't know what's going to happen right
and you wait and it goes yellow and the
light goes green and somebody opens the
door and in that moment you realize
you've never been in a freaking airplane
with the door open right terror go sorry
I'm spit I'm sorry terror terror terror
terror right so you go and then you know
if you're if you were smart you sat in
the back so you don't go first right and
then people start going out of the
airplane and you go and the guy walks
you up to the end of the thing and
you're standing and your toes are on the
edge and you're looking out down to
death and they say on three and they say
one two and he pushes you on to because
people grab on three right and you go
and you fall out of the airplane and in
one second you realize that it's the
most blissful experience of your life
you're flying right it doesn't feel like
falling right it's like that you
actually are kind of held a little bit
by the wind and then you start and you
you start falling you falling and you
there's zero fear you realize that the
point of maximum danger is the point of
minimum fear it's bliss it's bliss and
you're flying
right you're doing it and then 20
seconds 25 seconds 40 seconds and you
have enough time to just kind of be like
ah that's that building that's not like
that right you start doing all of that
and the the lesson for me was why were
you scared in your bed the night before
why did you what do you need that fear
for just don't go why are you scared in
your bed
16 hours before you jump why are you
scared in a car why could you not enjoy
breakfast what would what did you need
that that fear is fear of what you're
nowhere to even near the airplane
everything up to the stepping out
there's actually no reason to be scared
it only just ruins your day you don't
have to jump and then in that moment all
of a sudden where you should be
terrified is the most blissful
experience of your life and God placed
the best things in life on the other
side of terror on the other side of your
maximum fear or all of the best things
in life lesson number three stop
complaining what if I told you this was
the last Monday morning of your life
what if I told you you'd die this week
would you complain about your crap job
or that test you don't want to take I
doubt it you would go much higher level
thinking well that's really what it
takes it takes understanding that if
you're not pumped right now if you're
brunching what you're about to do if
you're if you're not looking forward to
it look I respect practicality you got
to go through school because your
parents want to you got to pay your rent
you got screwed in loans I get it but
please recognize the world we're living
in we're living in a world where there's
so much more opportunity this internet
thing created way more opportunity for
all of us
way more I mean look you might not even
be alive like your mom and dad could
have had sex like three minutes later
and you wouldn't even exist and you're
complaining you could have ended up
being
a tree I just don't get the mentality of
being head down sad on a Monday morning
I'm gonna make Monday morning my I'm
gonna make you Saturday Monday morning
that's what I want to do every morning
and that's what I want from you please
take a step back and think about how
awesome it actually is and then
recognize that you can attack the world
in a totally different way because you
were lucky enough to be born during this
era lesson number four know your
destination imagine we're standing in a
big empty room right and we're standing
in one corner and I give you a simple
instruction I want you to go to that
corner in a straight line right off you
go no big deal right without telling you
I slip a chair in front of you what do
you do you go around the chair now you
just disobeyed what I told you to do I
told you to go to that corner straight
line but this is the amazing things
about human beings which is when we're
given a clear destination we use our own
creativity and our own sense of
innovation and our own problem-solving
abilities to overcome obstacles to get
to the destination in other words the
destination is more important than the
route right we are flexible about the
route we're obsessed with the
destination reset we're standing in the
corner together and I give you a simple
instruction go somewhere in this room in
a straight line and you say to me well
where do you owe me to go I'm like I
don't know you smart figure it out go in
a straight line and so you pick a point
and you start walking and without
telling you I put a chair in front of
you and what do you do you come to a
grinding halt I say what did you stop
for you go will you put a chair in front
of me or you'll make a sudden turn and
go in another direction right and this
is the problem it's the same obstacle
the difference is when you have a clear
set a clear destination the obstacles
become easy to overcome when you don't
have a clear destination you keep coming
to a grinding halt and what we do in our
companies is we're counting the steps
we're taking along the route but we're
never looking at the destination right
so company says made in million dollars
this year we were only planning on
making eight hundred thousands like we
took ten steps were only planning on
taking eight where are you going no clue
right we count the steps and so the
point is is that people want to feel
that the effort that they're exerting
actually are moving somewhere and so
successful measurement successful
recognition is not just for the steps
you take it's not just for the effort
it's that the effort you exerted moved
us closer to where we're trying to get
to and that get to should be some crazy
ideal my ideal is to live in a world in
which the vast majority of people wake
up every single morning you know
inspired to go to work and fulfilled by
the work that they do and the the couple
of measurements that I use are if the
book is selling and I by the way people
ask me how many have you sold I have no
clue I've never asked the publisher
because they don't care I really don't
care have many I've sold what I care
about is the Amazon rankings and that
those are going steady or up and not
plummeting because that means other
people write because I don't have a
publicist I don't have a marketing
strategy on purpose I didn't hire one of
those companies to sell the book for me
and the reason is is because I'm not
interested in book sales I'm interested
the spreading of an idea and so I just
use that as a metric to help me
understand am I sort of marching in that
because the more I preach is it
resonating you know and so you have a
couple of these imperfect measurements
that help you understand are you going
along the way so it's not just great
effort look what you achieved because
that's what we're doing now right our
goal is to increase top-line revenues by
50 million dollars for what reason
right which is we have to know the
destination and then we say amazing you
took us that much closer and if we go to
the right it's because we were
overcoming an obstacle if we hadn't gone
to the right we would have been stuck
forever
thank you you know it's not always
straight lines it's not always straight
lines but it's it's in one direction
she's pulling the cane out I'm lesson
number five
enjoy life I'm not sure about that in
the future I think I would dictate I
would be stupid that's why I should
retire early when I'm young that is why
I have a lot of things that a dream I
want to do I'm under therapy I want to
be a teacher I want to go back to school
I want to do the environment and the
world is so wonderful why you should be
the CEO of Alibaba all the time I'm
coming to this world not to work I want
to come to this or to enjoy my life I
don't want to die in my office I'm going
to die on the beaches
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoy I'd love to learn what
did you learn from this video what was
your favorite lesson leave it down in
the comments below is there a lesson 6
or 7 that you want to add to the list
put it down the comments I'm looking
forward to hearing from you thank you
again for watching greetings again from
Copenhagen Denmark I believe in you hope
you continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon